And this idea of discipline,
obviously up.
I talk about discipline a lot.
And one of the things you were talking about earlier with regards to veterans
and people that have listened to your lectures.
And it's the same thing with me.
People that listen to this podcast or,
or read the books and,
and one of the things that I've noticed and I've talked about and I've gotten a
lot of positive feedback on is,
you know,
when you're in the military you have this discipline and beyond that,
beyond the discipline that's imposed on you,
you also have a lot that you have to just hold the line yourself.
I mean,
when you're in the military,
sure you go through boot camp where there's a drill instructor that Jellyvision
and all that.
But once you're in the military,
you're doing what you have to do.
It's self discipline that you learn that and you become self disciplined.
And what happens is guys get out and that's,
that's gone.
And that hurts them.
And the other thing that hurts them is they don't know what their mission is
anymore.
And,
and my big thing with people that have been telling vets now is find what your
next mission is.
Go find whatever your next mission.
And I don't care what it is,
but it has to be something.
And I was listening to you talk on something the other day and,
and you were,
you were talking about how
not doing anything when people are not going anywhere,
when they're,
when they're failing,
when they don't have the drive,
it's because they're not accepting responsibility for anything.
And,
and so my way of saying that is like you need a new mission,
you need to be responsible for something and you need to go and move towards
some new mission and,
and do you encounter people that,
or you see people that's very problematic in the civilian side as well,
where people,
they just don't know what they're doing.
I don't take any responsibility for anything.
Nihilism.
Is that because first of all,
you learned that truth is relevant relative and that there's no real moral order
and you know,
that alleviates,
you have responsibility and that's why that's such an attractive message to
people.
But the problem is,
is that it kills you.
It kills your soul,
so to speak,
because,
well,
when we can talk about this technically,
so you know,
there are systems,
neurological systems that underlie your experience of negative emotion.
And there are neurological systems that underlie your experience of positive
emotion.
And there are separate systems.
They obviously interact,
but they're separate systems.
So,
but the positive emotion system,
while there's two of them,
but one of them sort of kicks in when you get something that you want.
So you know you're hungry and you eat,
and that feels good.
And so that's kind of the simple one.
Um,
but there's a more sophisticated one that I think is even more.